hello everybody i'm martin clapman from
the university of cambridge
and i'm very happy to talk today at the
acm conference on distributed and
event-based systems
on thinking in events now
first of all thank you to the people who
support my work financially and to make
this possible
what i want to talk about today is a
kind of taxonomy of the big wide world
of event-based systems
the word event means many many different
things in different branches of
computing depending on who you
ask and i've spent the last 10 years or
so working on a variety of different
event-based systems both in industry and
in research
and through that i have built up
at least some kind of subjective uh
categorization taxonomy of
at least how i think about
differentiations between different types
of event-based systems
so i think this sort of analysis will
necessarily be subjective
to an extent um because it's simply such
a big area
um but i hope that the categorization
that i will talk about today will at
least be helpful to you as well in the
way that you think about event-based
systems
so when i think about events first
question i want to ask really is
well what exactly do we mean with
the different aspects of what an event
could be so to me an
event could be first of all a
notification
of the fact that something happened and
so a piece of code
some function gets called as a result of
something occurring that could be an
event
also an event could be a persistent
record of the fact that something
happened where that
record of something that happened is
written to disk so we can
retrieve it again later or it could be
both it could be a notification and a
record at the same time
so let me break those down a bit more to
see what we actually mean with that
so as a notification essentially i'm
thinking here like a callback function
or something like that which gets called
in order to handle something that
happened
classic example for this would be in a
user interface
where you have a button that the user
can click and when the user clicks the
button then some
function in the application code is
called to handle whatever
that button click should do likewise
with any other type of user input of
just moving the mouse cursor or typing
pressing a button on the keyboard
whatever it is
that's a classic example of events in
user interfaces
we also get events in different contexts
for example we get event loops
in io in an i o context where
say you want to be able to read and
write from several files or
we can write several network sockets and
so
you can have a non-blocking interface to
these
to these i o operations which allows you
to
wait on a bunch of file descriptors at
the same time and then when whenever any
of those file descriptors has some data
available to read or it has
managed to write the data in some buffer
then you uh get an event saying okay
what what has happened in that event
and then once you handle that you go
back around the loop again and you keep
repeating this
in in a loop so that's an event loop
event loops also
occur in simulation software for example
where the events would be simulated
uh occurrences of something rather than
real life occurrences but it's
very much a similar kind of thing and it
generalizes to more different
uh different types of programming models
as well so
reactive programming or functional
reactive programming or data flow
programming not exactly the same things
but
what they have in common is that they
are ways of
writing code that handles changing data
in some way or
another and so one example of this would
be a spreadsheet
the spreadsheet you can have a formula
in one cell that references the value in
another cell
and if the value in one of those input
cells changes then the result of the
formula automatically gets recalculated
and you see the updated value in in the
formula cell as well
and so this is just one example where
the change
of the data in one cell is an event this
is the data change is an occurrence
which then gets propagated through the
system through potentially multiple
formulas
in order to update all of the data that
depends on
on that particular input now all of
these uses of events as notifications
are ephemeral so that is an event that
only
exists in memory as a transient uh
thing of calling a piece of program code
essentially
but it's not usually the event itself is
not something that would be written to
disk normally because there's no
it has no lasting value it's just
something that is
part of the execution of a program
we could take a very different
perspective of events which is to say
actually we don't care about whether
there are notifications
we want events to be recorded in on disk
as a permanent record one example of
this would be in a time series database
which you might use for example to
record the readings from a sensor
so the sensor every minute sends you a
reading of the current temperature
you don't need to call any application
code every single minute when that
sensor gets a new value
all you want to do is to store those
values in a database so that afterwards
you can
draw a nice chart of how temperature
changed over time
and of course time series databases are
used for many other things besides some
sensor readings as well
in that case a a reading from the sensor
would be an event
a similar pattern occurs in data
warehousing
so there this is often used for business
analytics say for example if you want to
analyze the sales of a company
a standard way of representing that in a
database is what's called a star schema
or snowflake schema
where there's one table in the middle
that holds all of the things that
happened
all of the facts or in or events which
are usually time stamped each row
with for example how many uh pieces of
which product were sold to which
customer at what price
and so each each record
or each row in this fact table is really
an event
uh a record record of the fact that uh
something happened like
a particular product was sold and so in
these cases when we're talking about
persistent records
it's not really a notification mechanism
but it's rather
just in a way of ensuring that data is
recorded in a way that is later
available for querying and analysis
but we could combine these properties so
we could
take the persistent aspect of databases
and we could take the notification
aspect of
event loops and callbacks and fuse those
together
into something that i'm just going to
i'm just going to give that a label of
stream processing
uh for lack of a better term and in the
rest of the talk i'm going to
concentrate on this aspect of
events that are both persistent and
notifications and
uh drill down further what in the ways
we can look at that
so i'm going to call this stream
processing and
a couple of examples of systems that use
this approach
so for example some message brokers
that are used for communication between
different services in an in an
organization
you can have one service that enqueues a
message which is then delivered to some
other message
and this broker which handles the
messaging may or may not
write the message to disk as part of its
handling of that message
and so writing it to disk means that
even if the broker crashes you don't
lose their messages which is useful
although typically this is not long-term
storage of messages so typically the
messages get deleted
after they have been processed the actor
model and their various other different
programming models for distributed
systems
which eventually which involve sending
a message from one process or one thread
or
one machine one node to another
and you can think of descending and
delivering of messages as as events as
well
which may or may not be persistent
depending on the particular framework
you're using
um moving more over to the databases
world so in databases
uh you all know you can make a query and
inspect the
state of the database at one point in
time some databases also support
continuous queries or stream queries
where you don't just query a one-time
point in time snapshot of the database
but you actually keep the query open and
so then
later after you've issued the query
maybe some additional data comes in that
would change the result as a query
and in that case then the result of the
query gets updated
a bit like in the spreadsheet example
that we talked about earlier
and and you get you get back a feed of
updated results of this query um so this
is very useful
a a similar concept um appears also
in some databases under the name of
materialized view maintenance
a materialized view is essentially a
cache of the result of some query
so for example as i've got on the slide
here the query might be something like
you want to aggregate
the number of other the value of sales
for each calendar month
by the store in which they occurred
which is just a standard group by query
and then summing up the revenue for each
item that was sold and so you might want
to keep a cache of this
which is just a number uh for each month
and for each store
and this means now whenever a new sale
comes in so a new sale gets added to the
underlying table which is sales in this
case
uh you need to update the materialized
view which is the cache of these query
results and
like in stream queries this is again a
kind of notification mechanism
where the change in some underlying data
or some underlying set of facts
results in a change in this derived
piece of data this derived data set
that is a function of the underlying
data
and so all of these are i would say
examples
of event-based systems that have both
the persistent aspect and the
notification aspect
but they are an important distinction to
make
with those types of systems and that is
about windowing
this may seem like a bit of an obscure
implementation detail to focus on but i
think actually it's a very important
distinguishing detail
and a lot of the literature doesn't
really make this distinction very
explicit and so that's why i want to
call it out
very explicitly as a question that
should be asked
for the purposes of a taxonomy like this
so windowing means we are going to group
together
events that occur within some time
period of each other
and this is very often used if you want
to do
some kind of analytics uh over stream
based data
or complex event processing which means
combining
several events to spot patterns and to
to then generate some derived events
that are the result of combining several
input events
and so a simple example of windowing
would be that we simply want to group
together all of the events that occurred
on a certain day
or a certain week or a certain month
whatever unit of time you like
and perhaps we're just going to you know
calculate the sum of some value
per day or something like that some kind
of way we're going to take together
all of the events that occur within some
time period and treat them as one unit
and then each time period is separate
from the other time periods
that's one way of windowing there are
other ways as well so for example the
windows don't have to be
mutually exclusive you could have
overlapping windows
so something like a five-day moving
average over some data for example would
be
an example of a sliding window
or another example would be say you want
to correlate
two streams of events uh where events
will occur within some period of time
within each other so let's say you have
a car park
and you have a a sensor for
cars entering the car park and a sensor
for cars leaving the car park
and you want to work out how long has
each car been in the car park for
and so in order to do this you have to
join the entering event
with the exiting event and you can join
them by maybe having a number plate
reader
that identifies each car as it goes in
and comes out
and so here i've represented each car
each different
car with a different color and the join
between these events
uh by joining up the the two events with
a line
and you can see here that uh generally a
you can expect that a car will exit the
car park after it has entered the car
park so the
the period of time in which it stays in
the car park is usually a non-negative
amount of time although you could
imagine things with clock skew for
example where you might
actually observe a negative time after
all
but the question is now for windowing
purposes well is there some upper bound
that you can assume
so what is the maximum period of time
from
the car entering to the car exiting the
car park the maximum period of time that
you're going to assume and maybe it's
something like 24 hours
and if a car does spend more than 24
hours in the car park maybe it's going
to get
fine or something like that um because
you don't allow
long-term parking in this car park so uh
in this case if you can assume some kind
of upper bound
on the time period between the entry and
the exit event then you've got a
windowed
drawing here um because you are assuming
a maximum time bound on this thing
on an unwindowed join you are assuming
there's no upper bound
on the distance between the events that
you want to connect to each other
and in in a non-window join um
that means you know you don't you can't
just work on fixed time intervals
you have to potentially look arbitrarily
far back in time
in some other stream in order to do that
join so let me give you an example of a
system where you cannot do windowing
and where you do have to look back
arbitrarily fine time
and that is let's say we wanted to
implement twitter or some similar kind
of social media app
and if you use twitter you know the way
it works is that if you log in as a user
you see a bunch of tweets that were
written by the people you follow
and you can follow or unfollow people as
you desire
um and if you implement this in a kind
of relational schema kind of entity
relationship diagram style
you could say that uh the currently
logged in user has a many-to-many
relationship to the users they're
following so they
follow many users and the user may be
followed by many people
and then each tweet is sent by one
particular user
so each tweet has a unique author and so
if we now want to find all of the tweets
that were written by
users who the current logged in user is
following
that means we have to start with the
currently logged in user
we find using the follows table we
we find all of the the entries in the
followers table where the
follower id is the currently logged in
user
which then gives us the followee id is
the user who is being followed
then we find all of the tweets by the
user being followed where the sender id
of the tweet equals the
user being followed and then we print
out those tweets
after having sorted them by the
timestamp at which they were sent
and so this is a simple way how you
could implement twitter
and in fact i think it is how twitter
was implemented in the very early days
but it turned out to be very expensive
because people
often will read their list of tweets so
people log in and refresh their page and
so on very often
much more often than people actually
send new tweets and so
they ended up having to cache the result
of this query or alternatively
make a materialized view of what they
call the home timeline and so the home
timeline is
what you see when you log in which is
all the recent tweets by people you're
following
so let's think a bit about how we would
construct this cache or this
materialized view
of the home timeline so we can think of
twitter as an event-based system where
there are maybe two or three types of
events
firstly a user can send a tweet uh
that's one type of event
and the user can follow another user
that's another type of event
and maybe a user can unfollow a
different user that's a third type of
event
okay and so now the
uh the input to our system are just
these events of sending tweets and
following and unfollowing
and we want to compute the timeline the
home timeline
as a function of those input events and
you can think of this
as being essentially a join between the
sending tweet event and the following
uh event so if user a follows user b
and then sometime later in point in time
user b sends a tweet
then we want to add that tweet by user b
to the timeline of user a because user a
is following user b
but the time when user a followed user b
might be a long time ago it might be 10
years ago that the user signed up for
twitter they followed
user b and then 10 years later that user
b sends a tweet
and so what this shows us here is
there's no upper bound we can assume on
the time between the following event
and the sending tweet event uh so
there's no way we can use windowed joins
here this has to be a non-window
join in order to be able to deal with
the fact that
you know once you follow someone you
that lasts forever
until you one day unfollow them again
so if we wanted to implement this in
pseudocode let's say
we maintain some state in this stream
join
the state is for each user we maintain
the current list of followers of that
user
and whenever we get an event that says
that
a now follows b we find the list of
followers for user
b and add user a to the set of followers
for b we do the under reverse when a
unfollows b
we simply find that set of followers and
remove a from the set of followers
and then when we get a sendtweet event
well then
when if a sends a particular tweet we
find all of the followers of
a then we find the timeline for each of
the followers
for each of the followers and we add the
new tweet to the timeline to that
appropriate timeline
and so what this gives us is essentially
a materialized view
of this sql query that we talked about
earlier so
we have taken our input events
uh our facts which are the the sending
tweet events the follow and unfollow
events
and from this we have derived a
materialized view which is the home
timeline for a particular user
and this has been an example of a
non-windowed join so
i was just making this distinction
between windowed and non-windowed
i think we've seen enough examples of
the windowed systems
so i'm going to now drill down further
on the non-windowed
side of things and so we've seen the
twitter
home timelines as example as one example
of a materialized view
which required a non-windowed join
we can also look at database replication
which also
has quite similar characteristics to
this it might seem like
i'm jumping around the topics quite
wildly here but you'll see that there
are actually
some quite common similar ideas here
so let's think about database
replication as an event-based system
so there are different ways how you can
implement replication
you know you can have gossip protocols
you can have anti-entropy and so on
what i'm going to focus on right now is
log-based replication which is perhaps
the most common
where you have one designated database
node which
is the the leader or the primary or the
master and
whenever you want to write to the
replicated system you make your rights
to this leader node and then the leader
executes some kind of replication
protocol
by which the other replicas whom
we might call those followers or backups
those other replicas
also receive a copy of the data that was
written to the leader
and the idea here being that
any data that is written to the leader
also gets written to all of the other
replicas and so
at least after their replicas have
caught up then all of the
replicas should be in the same state
they should contain the same data
and with log-based replication the way
this works is that
the leader maintains a log
and every time that some data is written
to the leader an event
or a record is appended to the end of
this replication log
and this replication log just grows in
an append only way
as events are added and after an event
has been written to the log the log is
immutable
now any follower that wants to have a
copy of the data in the leader
it now reads this replication log
sequentially it simply starts from the
beginning and processes it
one event at a time and it reads those
events in the log for those records
and applies them to its own copy of the
database and as it does so one
after a time it will repeat exactly the
same sequence of writes that were made
on the leader
and when the follower has reached the
end of the log then we know that it will
be in the same
state as the leader and so this is
standard stuff and it works very well
and
there are two key characteristics of a
log that make this
form of replication work firstly the log
is totally ordered which means that
you know all all replicas see exactly
the same sequence of log records and
they see them in the same order
and secondly it's append only so we only
append
new events at the end of the log and
thereafter they remain
immutable and we don't go and back go
back and change
past chunks of the replication log
so each of these entries in the log we
can think of as an event
and we might now ask how do we actually
construct one of these logs
well there are two ways how this can be
done usually
one is that the people who set the set
up the systems that
administrators of the database
designated one of the machines to be the
leader
and so they fix the configuration in
such a way that okay this machine is the
leader the others are the secondaries or
the followers
and if the leader becomes unavailable
then the humans who set up the system
manually reconfigure the system to use
one of the other replicas as leader
instead
alternatively you can use a consensus
algorithm such as paxos or raft or
any of the others which essentially does
the same thing but automatically with
automatic election of leader
and automatic process for changing over
to a new leader if the old leader dies
but both of these are essentially just
forms of constructing
such a replication log now there are two
different ways
how we can think about this replication
log and i want to distinguish those now
so the most common that people are
probably familiar with
is what's called primary backup
replication which is exactly what i said
just now so
when the user wants to write some data
they make a
database transaction on the primary or
on the leader
in that database transaction they can
read and write the database in whatever
way they like
and any mutations they make to the state
of the database so any changes they make
for example inserting updating or
deleting some rows
the database records any such changes
that were made
which uh those changes are essentially a
side effect of executing the transaction
and the database then records any of
those changes in the replication log
this replication log could be a logical
log which means that it records the
uh which table had which row is inserted
and deleted
or it could be a physical log which is
literally in this block on disk we've
replaced this range of bytes with this
new
range of bytes um both work
both are used in practice they have
slightly different trade-offs but both
are examples of this primary backup
replication
where the replication log really is a
side effect of the transactions that
were executed on the primary
and the the backups or the secondary
uh replicas they don't execute a
transaction all they do is apply the
changes that were described in the
replication block
there's a different way we could also do
replication
which swaps around those roles so in
primary backup replication
this mutation the database is the
primary data model
and any log any events in the log are a
side effect
of executing the transaction we can also
do state machine replication while
similar concept is known as event
sourcing
essentially different phrasings of the
same idea
uh in which we swap around those two
roles and we say
when the user interacts with the system
and when the user wants to write data to
the system
they don't actually speak directly to a
database
replica instead they construct an event
that describes the change they want to
make
and append that event to a log
so the log is now actually the primary
data model for writing to the system
now all of the replicas now consume this
log and they execute some deterministic
logic on every event
that appears in the log and so now
because every replica will see the same
events in the same order because it's a
log
and they execute the same deterministic
logic then those events
those replicas will move each replica
will move through the same sequence of
states because of the
deterministic logic and so they will end
up in the same state um
so we end up with the same effect that
the replicas
have the same data in them and you can
read from those replicas as the read
data model in the system
um but we have now swapped around the
roles and so
this um the log in state machine
replication and the events in the log
actually become the primary data model
for how we write to the system
and the state of the replicas is
actually derived from the event log
in the way that kind of resembles state
machine replica in a way that resembles
um materialized view maintenance like we
were talking about earlier
so why do we have those two different
approaches to replication well there's
some very good reasons why you might
want to use
state machine replication so let's take
as an example
a system where students can enroll in
courses and cancel their enrollment
again and so on so
typical university-based course
management system and so
an event in the log in in such a system
might be something like
student x cancel the enrollment in
course y for reason z
that's it so it's a very nice compact
uh descriptive like description
of what happened the of the event that
occurred
whereas if you look at the replication
log that a primary backup system would
produce
as a result of the equivalent change was
well you might have a bunch of tables
and maybe one table contains the
enrollments and so the cancellation of
the enrollment corresponds to deleting
a row from the enrollment table maybe
you have a separate reason to record the
cancellation reasons so we would add a
row to that table
maybe you also have for example the
the number of available places as a
denormalized field as essentially a
cache
on the course table and so then if a
student
cancels their enrollment that means you
also have to increment the number of
available places
so if you look at the log event in the
top
section here you can see that you can
reconstruct from it the fact that it
must have been
a an enrollment a cancellation of an
enrollment but it's quite an indirect
there's a lot of irrelevant detail there
about the current database schema and
how it happens to be implemented whereas
the log event in the state machine
replication approach is actually a very
nice
beautiful descriptive self-contained
uh event that's um that you know is a
lot easier to interpret
as a human working with the system
so that is one example one one reason
why you might want to use state machine
replication because these descriptive
events are actually very nice to work
with
another reason why you might want to use
state machine replication
is that the fact that you have derived
the replica state
from the events in the log through some
deterministic logic
means now the log is not modified by
consuming these events the events are
still there in the log
and so you can go come along and process
the events again
so for example if you decide that you
want to change the logic that you use
for interpreting
an event and maybe for example maybe
previously you didn't have this
available places field
and you want to add the available places
to field to the schema
you now have to populate this field
somehow and so this means now you have
to actually go
back and well somehow you have to
recompute the value of that field
one way of doing that would be to just
write your new
event interpretation logic which
which does the updating of the number of
available places
or which fixes a bug that you previously
had in the event updating logic
and now you scan through the whole log
of events from beginning to end
process each log event write them to a
new replica
and the result you've now got a new
system that has been
um that has been processed through some
new logic uh without actually changing
the underlying data this is really cool
this is something you can't really do
in the mutable state type databases
where you know once you've made the
change to the database that's it there's
there's no description of why you made
that change all you have is that you
know so
one row was updated from this value to
that value but
it doesn't include any explanation of
why that happened or how you might do it
differently another time
so this means the state machine
replication or event sourcing approach
is very good if you need to explain how
the system got into a certain state
which you might need for audit purposes
or for debugging for example
so here the pros and cons of state
machine replication
versus primary backup replication as i
said um
the nice thing about events is they can
be very nicely descriptive
and so if you're in a business for
example uh often events will correspond
very well to
an action that occurred on the business
level so this is some
an event is something that can make
sense to non-technical people as well
so people who don't care about the
current database schema but who do care
about the business processes that these
events are describing
as i we talked about auditability and
debugging we talked about
being able to have potentially several
different views onto one underlying log
by just processing the events in several
different ways
and even the ability to change the event
processing logic
after the fact and reprocessing events
using a new logic
downsides of state machine replication
well you've got this extra level of
indirection
first you have to write the event and
then you have to translate the event
into the the current view the the read
optimized view
onto those events so that's but it can
be extra work
in some systems that might not be worth
it subtlety happens
if you want to be able to validate an
event before appending it to the log
for example if you want if you are
selling seats in a theater you want to
ensure you don't sell the same seat in
the theater twice to two different
people
um so that requires before you write
that seat
before you write that seat booking event
to the log you have to actually check
the
seat being booked is still available and
that requires an up-to-date view of
what is the booking status of every seat
is it still available or not
so that can require a little bit of
extra care
this whole idea of recording all of the
events in an append only log can be
expensive if the rate
at the rate at which events are coming
in is very high
um and so you know if it's a very high
volume system it might not be
reasonable to store all of the events
forever and we process them on demand
but in many systems the event of the
rate of events to be honest is just not
that high
and so actually reprocessing them is
entirely feasible
and one more point there that is
important is
that in some systems you actually do
need to delete data for example
for gdpr purposes a user can request for
their data to be deleted under the right
to be forgotten
and this means you really do have to
delete their personal
data how do you do this if you have an
append
only log where an event is immutable
after it has been written
so this suggests that you do actually
need some way of
rewriting the log to remove any user
data that has to be deleted
or maybe you do something like encrypt
the user data in such a way that you can
then forget the encryption key
and that way then you can leave it in
the log but you just can't decrypt it
anymore
um another one thing i might mention in
this context that if you're interested
in blockchains or distributed ledgers
they are essentially the same thing as
state machine replication if you think
about it
so the chain of blocks is just the
totally ordered
uh records uh the log events
and uh okay you might have a byzantine
consensus protocol around it and a bit
more security stuff
but the basic principle of you know
having some events in a log
and executing those events in order to
determine the current state
uh like in a blockchain that might
cryptocurrency that might be the current
value of every account um you know that
is essentially
doing state machine replication as well
so
both primary backup replication and
state machine replication i said rely on
this totally ordered log
which means that every replica processes
the event in exactly the same order
and that is that is wonderful if for
purposes of getting the replicas into
the same state
but it does incur a cost and that cost
is because
everyone all of the replicas have to
agree on the order in which the events
appear in the log
which excuse me means that on every
event you want to append to the log
you have to talk to the leader and wait
for a response to the leader before you
know at which position your event
appears in the log
which means that if you're running this
protocol over long distances
where there's a substantial round trip
time it can get quite slow
um it gets even worse if you're talking
about data that's on mobile devices and
so on mobile devices
say you have a to-do list on your phone
and you want to sync that with the to-do
list on your laptop
and you know this is or it might be a
calendar it might be notes something
like this
and you still want this app to work even
if you don't have network connectivity
right now so even if your phone
currently can't connect to the network
because you're on a train going through
a tunnel or because you're in a
supermarket where you can't get any
cellular data reception
or whatever reason many reasons why you
might want you still want the software
and your phone to work you still want to
be able to check your to-do lists
to change items to add new items to your
to-do list
and so now if you are disconnected
there's no way we can use a totally
ordered replication log between your
phone and your laptop
because any change that you want to make
in the case of this
replication log would require talking to
a leader and that simply is not possible
if your phone is disconnected from the
network
so that raises the question now if we do
want this thing to work on mobile
devices
where the devices might be offline what
equivalent do we have to the totally
ordered event log
so the totally evented totally ordered
event log will only work in the case
where the users are online and able to
connect to the leader
so the alternative that we have in the
if we want to support offline working is
we use a partial order rather than
a total order interestingly there's a
connection here
to the cap theorem if you thought about
that so
the totally ordered event log
corresponds exactly to the consistent
and partition tolerant category
in the cap theorem sense whereas the
partial order corresponds to the highly
available type systems
in the cap theorem sense and so the
distinction
between totally ordered and partially
ordered is that well totally ordered is
just
a linear order as you would expect
partial order
means you can have some kind of
branching and then things can occur
concurrently
and then branches can merge together and
you can have any number of branches
potentially existing in parallel
and so the structure that you get here
out get out rather than log is
essentially a directed a
acyclic graph or a dag um if you worked
with
git commit histories for example that's
an example of a partial order
where you have a dag of commits um and
because git allows you to make commits
offline it has exactly this property
that it's impossible to enforce a total
order
unless you do stuff like rebasing after
the fact of course
now i'm now going to focus on these
partially ordered systems for a while
but i want to clear out of the way a
point of confusion that might exist
there
which is that even in a partially
ordered system it is possible to make a
total order
uh so even though we're staying within
this partially ordered category let me
explain what i mean because this is
maybe a bit confusing
let's say we have two replicas and we
have each replica has a set of
events and we're going to give each
event a timestamp
um this timestamp is not going to be
from a physical clock so it doesn't tell
you like
tuesday at 4pm it might just be a
logical timestamp
which means it consists essentially of a
counter together with the id of the
replica that generated a particular
event and so i'm now going to say that
the event a
uh and event b were both generated by
replica a and so they were given logical
timestamps one and two
respectively together with the id of the
replicas generated them which is the
capital a
now let's say that the two replicas want
to add
new events to their set of events and so
replica a wants to add events c and d
and replica b
wants to add events x and y and
in a partially ordered system these uh
additions of events can happen without
any coordination so even if the replicas
are unable to communicate with each
other right now because they're offline
they can still add new events to the set
they can generate these logical
timestamps for their events
um but sometime later after the fact
network communication will occur because
the network network becomes available
again
and now these replicas have to merge
together their events
and now this is where the total order
comes in it is still possible to put all
of these events in a total order
because we can simply order the events
by their timestamp
i'm going to say the timestamp ordering
here is we're first going to compare the
counterparts
and so if we'll put the events with the
smaller counter
first and the events with the higher
counter later and then if we have
several events with the same counter
then we're going to compare their
replica ids
and that's going to give us a unique
total order and so here in this example
i put 3a before 3b because we're going
to say a comes before b
and then 3b comes before 4a because 3 is
less
than 4 and then 4a comes before 4b
and so now both replicas agree on the
total order in which the events should
occur
however this is even though it's a total
order it's not a log
because it's not append only because if
you look at this from the point of view
of replica b for example
replica b first had a b x y
and then later it learns about the
events c and d and they can't just
append these events at the end of its
log
or the end of it set a sequence of
events because
then the replicas would not have the
same order of events
so replica b has to insert the c and and
the d
earlier on in its sequence of events and
that's what makes it not
a log because we have to go back and
insert uh
events somewhere retroactively in the
middle of this totally ordered sequence
but nevertheless even though it's not a
log we can still
use it in similar kind of ways as we use
state machine replication so in state
machine replication as we said
we just process the events in the order
in which they appear in the log
in this case we're just going to process
the events deterministically in
their increasing timestamp order um
and we could still build up a
materialized view onto this we can still
do all of the stuff we did earlier
in in state machine replication and we
will still
because the two replicas do eventually
end up with the same sequence of events
if they process the events in the same
order they will still end up in the same
derived state from this we just have to
deal with the fact that events now might
arrive
out of order and so therefore we have to
do this insertion of event
somewhere into the middle of this event
sequence so let's take for example that
we've got
the state a b c x d y
and then a new event k comes in and the
new event has a timestamp of 3c
so that means we have to put it between
the event x and the event d that's where
it's going to have to slot in
in this sequence of events and so
what we would need to do now here is to
first of all roll back the state
and go back to the point in time after
we've just applied abx
abc x but before we've applied dy
so this requires some way of jumping
back to an earlier state of the database
we could probably do that with keeping
some regular snapshots for example and
then
jumping back to the most recent snapshot
before the insertion point and then
replaying the events from that point
onwards something along those lines
so now we've got a prefix of our
sequence of events we put the new event
k
in the place where it belongs according
to the timestamp ordering
we processes that event k and then we
replay
any events that we previously undid and
put those after the newly inserted event
k
and so by doing this reverse and then
processing the event and then replaying
the events forward again
we get essentially the same effect as if
we had been doing state machine
replication
but we get it without actually having a
log without having this event only
property at this append only property
and this technique is called time warp
it was written
a long time ago already and uh
it was developed i think for for
simulation systems but you could use it
in any sort of data systems really
and time warp has some of the advantages
of state machine replication so it has
the state machine replication like
mapping of events to state and you can
use arbitrary logic as long as it's
deterministic
to do that mapping from events to state
but
the advantage of a state machine
replication is that the replicas can
still read and write
their state while they're offline um
because we don't require this agreement
on the order
of the events as they are appended to
the log
the downside of time warp is well you
have to do this rollback and replay
which can be expensive if you have to
insert a new event somewhere far back
in in the event log history um
and this whole idea of reverting back to
an earlier state works fine as long as
the state is encapsulated within our
system
it gets more difficult if we can have
external side effects
on other parts of the world and in those
cases like for example if you send an
email
as a side effect of processing an event
and then later you realize that actually
that event you processed is no longer
valid because you had to insert a new
event ahead of it
well you can't unsend the email i guess
you could send a follow-up email saying
that uh sorry we got that wrong it's now
the state is now something different
but you know if you really can't afford
this kind of
apologies then you can't use time warp
you have to use a state machine
replication instead and you have to
accept a cost that it won't work offline
so that's the distinction between
uh total order and partial order that we
talked about
and i want to now sort of break this in
a sort of two by two matrix and say
we talked about time warp as this
example of a system where the event
generation is partially ordered even
though then we do afterwards put the
events in a total order by timestamp but
the
events structured themselves is
partially ordered
and timewarp is what we get if we have
this data model
of immutable events where we process the
event through some deterministic logic
to get
the current database state if we do the
same thing with the immutable events
but use a totally ordered log as input
instead well we get state machine
replication as we talked about
on the other hand we could change the
data model and instead of appending
events
to a log we could say our data model is
um
to is to
write do a transaction on the primary
and then to write the side effects of
that transaction
uh to the replication log that's primary
backup replication so in that case we're
treating
the applications data model that we're
working with is this mutable state where
the database state can be mutated
by the application so this raises the
question now what do we get
if we take the partial ordering from
time warp
and the mutable state approach to the
data model
from primary backup replication and the
answer is we get something called
conflict pre-replicated
data types or crdts and i want to talk
that about that
in my last few minutes so crdts are
really good in this sort of system where
you've got replicas that need to be able
to update their stage while they're
offline
and then re-synchronize sometime later
so building again on the to-do list
example
we have let's say we have a to-do list
sync between phone and laptop and we
might represent the 2d list as a
json-like data structure something like
this and
so we can have each item on the to-do
list as as a record in a list
where each each one now has the
title which is by milk for example or
watering the plants
and the done field corresponds to
a done field is a boolean that
corresponds to the check box
on whether a particular item has been
done or not
and so now we can update the state of
this we can mutate the state of this
database
and for example by checking the checkbox
on watering the plants we're setting
this down field
from fourth to true and maybe a
different user
wants to add a new item to do to the
to-do list say we need to do the laundry
and adds this as an item to uh to this
list of to-do items
and you can imagine those things
happening concurrently of course because
the devices might be offline
um maybe if you've got a to-do list
synced between you and your partner
maybe you make a change on your device
while it's offline concurrently
your partner makes a change on their
device and then you have to merge those
two together
and in this example here of the to-do
list there's a reasonably logical
resolution of how to do that merge we
just keep the
done true on the water in the plants and
we keep the insertion of doing the
laundry
and what crdts are is essentially a set
of algorithms
that performs exactly this conflict
resolution and this kind of merging
for different types of data so it's a
way of
describing mutable data in such a way
that we record exactly what changes are
being made
as a side effect of the user interacting
with the application in some way or
another
and we can package up the those
um those mutations that the user made as
events or operations they're called in
the crdt literature
and we can propagate those operations or
events
from one device to another and we then
have a way of
updating the other devices state in such
a way
that everyone ends up with the same
state at the end and the changes that
were made by different users can
currently are merged together cleanly
so this is what crdt has given us it's
it's a way of managing data that does
work
offline like time warp it's a a
partially ordered system it allows
different replicas
to make progress independently from each
other even if there's no communication
possible right now
on the other hand differently from time
warp it does not require this rollback
and replay
structure normally because crtts are
designed to have
operations that are commutative so the
operations carry some extra metadata
and making them commutative means you
can apply the operations of the events
in a different order on each replica and
still end up with the same state at the
end
and so this now allows us this means we
don't have to flatten the total order
at the the partial order into a total
order we don't have to do the rollback
and replay
we can just apply the events as they
occur
to the state and the crdt algorithm
ensures that we nevertheless converge to
the same state on all of the replicas
so crdts are particularly good model
particularly good approach for those
applications that have this kind of
state mutation like
data model so if you're thinking about a
text editor for example
text editor is all about state mutation
because you've got a
state which is the current text document
and you can mutate that state by typing
letters
and that is inserting or deleting
characters at any point
in in the document and so um this state
mutation fits very well to crdts if as a
way of
um generating those events then which
describe those edits to
to the text document and the nice thing
about crdts is that they are
like ready-made packaged algorithms
where the application doesn't need to
provide any conflict resolution logic
normally
um because the cldt itself handles these
things and so for example if you have
several users inserting new to-do list
items at the same position in the to-do
list
then the crdt will ensure that
nevertheless everyone ends up with the
same
sequence of to-do list items on their
screens the same items in the same order
a downside of crdt is that um
there are certain predefined data types
that you can use like
you know lists and maps and structures
like that you can't
very easily make your own uh data types
it's it's a fair bit of work to to
design your own crdts and the types of
operations that you can do are also
predefined so for example
there are many data types for ordered
sequences like lists
but not many of them allow you to
reorder the items in a sequence so
that's
something that can be added but it's um
not very easily done by applications
and finally the term conflict-free
people sometimes debate about a bit
because uh in the end essence you know
you can have built-in conflict
resolution policies
which mean that most uh conflicts due to
concurrent updates are resolved
automatically
but it's not entirely conflict-free
really in the strict sense
so to zoom out and recap we started
we're talking about the the the
landscape of event-based systems
by first of all asking are we talking
about notifications here are we talking
about persistent records of things that
happened
or even both of them we then broke down
the persistent notifications
uh channel of this further looked at
windowing and non-windowing
windowing gives us sort of stream
analytics and cep
style things non-windowing takes us in
the direction of materialized views and
database replication
and then finally for database
replication and materialized use
we did this two by two square comparing
both the data model that you can use
and the ordering guarantee that the
underlying system
produces and that is the taxonomy that i
wanted to talk about
so i hope that you found that useful way
of just thinking about all the different
things you can do with events
it's by no means exhaustive and it's
somewhat subjective to my personal view
um but maybe it's something you will
find useful as well
there is a paper that accompanies this
talk which uh includes a whole bunch of
extra material that unfortunately i
don't have time to talk about uh right
now
and so there's some case studies based
on systems that i've worked on
personally
including the apache kafka ecosystem for
stream processing
and local first collaboration software
and finally some ideas on future
research ideas
uh on event-based systems so
i hope you can check out the paper as
well which is at the url here on the
slide
and feel free to contact me with any
questions for those of you at the
conference
i'm of course available for any
questions now as well
thank you very much for listening